for me what makes it unique is just
the amounts of people here who are
really smart and driven to
work together to better understand what
happening in the world and to act there
on it for the benefit my whole body
is to be able to design a model
of learning or a machine which
can really understand the nuances of
natural language and power better
understand respond to people in ways
more specific is more correct
why did i found milan
because I have a dream a dream for
artificial intelligence that gives back
to society to enable change
the way we get around
make things as we could
not do it before saved lives
with personalized medicine
I'm working in the middle on a project that
aims to teach robots to understand
commitment and perform tasks
my dream is to be able to eliminate
a lot of stress in everyone's life
the world and perhaps also to help
characters and then nobody us
[Music]
but the star and his illness
I want to ensure that our
algorithms are the most efficient
possible and do not require both
astronomical databases for
to ensure that intelligence
artificial is accessible to the most
large number
my job is to support
companies to integrate solutions
artificial intelligence in the
project my goal is to develop
artificial intelligence methods
in order to discover a beast spear of
materials allowing us to better
fight against change
climatic
I didn't know we develop algorithms
to help women in these cases
develop more drugs
quickly be from the middle going
really allows us more and our
various research projects
internal as you know we are not in
full heart of a great revolution
energy which will take more and more
more jobs for us just to think
to new sources of energy
renewable to customers who go
become self-producers
digitization of our equipment 11 in
justice' last tick or on
energetics
so to face these challenges where
associate ourselves with the best in
world by obliging certified and have a
major impact on mad society
it's important that an actor like the
1000 ha be there to help train the
people helping businesses take off at
world leaders in this field
and also be present to reflect
with the company's milk on the
social issues impact both
essential because all these
changes there we must make them in the
respect for our humanist values
[Music]
at